what we're going to do in this video is
look at a tangible example where we
calculate angular velocity but then
we're going to see if we can connect
that to the notion of speed so let's
start with this example where once again
we have some type of a ball tethered to
some type of centre of rotation right
over here let's say this is a it's
connected with a string and so if you
were to move the ball around it would
move along this blue circle in either
direction and let's just say for the
sake of argument the length of the
string is 7 meters and we know that at
time is equal to 3 seconds our angle is
equal to theta is equal to PI over 2
radians which we've seen in previous
videos we would measure from the
positive x axis just like that and let's
say that at T is equal to 6 seconds T is
equal to 6 seconds theta is equal to PI
radians and so after 3 seconds the ball
is now right over here and so if we
wanted to actually visualize how that
happens let me see if I can rotate to
this ball in 3 seconds so it would look
like this one-mississippi
two-mississippi three-mississippi let's
do that again it would be
one-mississippi two-mississippi
three-mississippi so now that we can
visualize or conceptualize what's going
on see if you can pause this video and
calculate two things so the first thing
that I want you to calculate is what is
the angular velocity of the ball and
actually would be the ball and every
point on that string what is that
angular velocity which we denote with
Omega and then I want you to figure out
what is the speed of the ball so what is
the speed see if you can figure out both
of those things and four extra points
see if you can figure out our
relationship between the two all right
well let's do angular velocity first I'm
assuming you've had a go at it
angular velocity you might remember is
just going
to be equal to our angular displacement
which we could say is Delta Theta and it
is a vector quantity and we are going to
divide that by our change in time so
delta T and so what is this going to be
well this is going to be our angular
displacement our final angle is PI pi
radians minus our initial angle PI over
2 radians and then all of that is going
to be over our change in time which is 6
seconds which is our final time minus
our initial time minus 3 seconds and so
we are going to get in the numerator we
have been rotated in the positive
direction PI over 2 radians because it's
positive we know it's counter clockwise
and that happened over 3 seconds and so
we could rewrite this as this is going
to be equal to PI over 6 and let's
remind ourselves about the units our
change in angle that's going to be in
radians and then that is going to be per
second so we're going PI over 6 radians
per second and if you do that over 3
seconds well then you're going to go PI
over 2 radians now with that out of the
way let's see if we can calculate speed
if you haven't done so already pause
this video and see if you can calculate
it well speed is going to be equal to
the distance the ball travels and we've
touched on that in other videos I
encourage you to watch those if you
haven't already the distance that we
travel we could denote with s s is
sometimes used to denote arc length or
the distance traveled right over here so
the speed is going to be our arc length
divided by our change in time divided by
our change in time but what is our arc
length are going to be well we saw in a
previous video where we related angular
displacement to arc length or distance
that our arc length is nothing more than
the absolute value of our of our angular
displacement of our angular displacement
times the radius
the radius and in this case our radius
would be seven meters so if we
substitute all of this up here what are
we going to get we are going to get that
our speed our speed I'm writing it out
because I don't want to overuse well I
am overusing s but I want people to get
confused our speed is going to be equal
to the distance we travel which we just
wrote is our the magnitude of our
angular displacement and this is all
fancy notation but when you actually
apply it it's pretty straightforward
times the radius of the circle I guess
you can say we are we are we are
traveling along so let me write that in
a different color so times the radius
all of that over our change in time all
of that over our change in time well we
could put in the numbers right over here
we know that this is going to be PI over
two you take the absolute value of that
is still going to be PI over two we know
that our radius in this case is the
length of that string it is seven meters
and we know that our change in time here
we know that this over here is going to
be three seconds and we can calculate
everything but what's even more
interesting is to recognize that what is
what is this right over here what is the
absolute value of our angular
displacement over change in time well
this is just the absolute value of our
angular velocity so we could say that
speed speed is equal to the absolute
value of our angular velocity absolute
value of our angular velocity times our
radius times our radius and now so this
is super useful our speed in this case
is going to be PI over six radius
radians per second so PI over PI over
six times the radius times seven meters
times seven meters and so what do we get
we are going to get seven PI over six
meters per meters per second which will
be our units for speed here and the
reason why we're doing the absolute
values because remember speed is a
scalar quantity we're not specifying the
direction in fact the whole time we're
traveling our direction is constantly
changing so there you have it there's
multiple ways to approach these types of
questions but the big takeaway here is
one how we calculated angular velocity
and then how we can relate angular
velocity to speed and what's nice is
there's a nice simple formula for it and
all of this just came out of something
that relates to what we learned in
seventh grade around the circumference
of the circle which we touch on in the
video relating angular displacement to
arc length or a distance traveled